their message is loud and it is clear
without them these Farmers say there'd
be no food thousands of them brought
their tractors and their protests to
Central Berlin on Monday to tell the
politicians enough is enough up and down
the country they say the problems are
clear hatut NOA runs a 950 hectare Farm
in Brandenburg it's been in his family
for Generations the main products are
dairy crops and vegetables for him the
price of agricultural diesel is a real
issue but it doesn't stop there he says
what matters is clear and understandable
government
policies this m full now the barrel is
full almost overflowing and people are
showing their discontent it's not just
about the diesel It's the whole system
our agricultural system no longer works
we would live better and live more
peacefully if we had prices that covered
costs and Farms could live sensibly
could survive the old saying goes that
when the farmer prospers so do the
villages and the countryside it's a view
the Finance Minister says he shares
which is why he Brave the often loud
crowds at the demonstration in Berlin
there is no mistaking the level of anger
these people feel at Finance Minister
Lindner and his government he says he
can hear them he says he understands
their problems but the central question
they're asking is is what is he going to
do about
them not be those who suffer more than
others and here we
agree but everyone must make a
contribution State subsidies and
pandemic era Cuts in Bat will expire but
subsidies for agricultural diesel won't
right
now but will that be enough for people
like harmut NOA although the farmers
week-long campaign was planned to end on
Monday harmut says some in the farming
Community are already considering more
radical strike action Dominic Kane Al
jazer
Berlin make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer